hey am I in the frame work to a million
does anybody know if I'm in a trade oh
cool
hey everybody how's it going cuz i zoom
it doesn't but not much
it's wide-angle lens would ya you will
just get over here man yeah man is it
I'll get next matter hello everyone
today you're going to do a taste test of
Swedish Fish Oreos
I don't even know how you put swedish
fish flavor into an Orion give me one
open the box yeah cut to the crap now do
we think it's gonna be good or gross
gross I think it's gonna be fine like I
need it I just don't think it's gonna
taste like a swedish fish icing oh it's
about as oh wait is it actually
swedish fish in the middle don't worry
or is it like hi I'm bill that's give it
to me wait why don't you open it really
I don't know you know what I'm Swedish
Fish I've never been like you know we
should mix this with chocolate cookies
here we are here we are you know I like
my Oreos yeah I know how you like the
top split off I only half the Oreo oh
yes way more movie-like so I only eat
the side the honey ice all right oh no
mother can I take two and then come on
everyone all right you're gonna make a
double scotch baby this stuff yeah put
it in my mouth
hey I got the dog here this is Ollie -
do you want one I smelled that one in my
mouth
I just ate the cookie part I'm trying it
on top no don't do that
down to the bad for dogs you get out of
here
it tastes like you were to put a swedish
fish inside of an Oreo and then
searching confused like that's exactly
what it is it really is was supposed to
be like that's what it tastes like
no I'm gonna do I'm gonna do experiment
just get the filling and then put it
together that's right oh really well
imagine a sweet fish that isn't chewy
and sticking to your teeth yes and
actually in the middle of an Oreo and it
tastes exactly like it will die in a way
I'm actually genuinely surprised me Joe
I don't think I would ever choose to eat
sweet as Vittorio's I think that was a
mistake on their body absolutely I just
go for Swedish now if you come at me
with a starburst for you then we got
something to talk about
okay so I'm just taking off the red let
me eat this yeah it's got bad a taste
it's got liked it I'm very weird
consistency
but it's weird v not sure well Manny
give me kisses
that my son does not taste like swedish
fish it only tastes like smell we never
chew on those yo but I rocks what you
Oreo hit me up on Twitter god I look I
love you right so go Madi yes general
knob I got some chocolate cake what's up
girl cool thanks for watching this is a
really great video quality YouTube
content yes um if you guys would like to
get you better idea description you're
not gonna upload it give it immediately
why would I mean to somebody know what
I'm eating
with my problem I'm problem it tastes
just like a swedish fish stuff in
between Oreo cookie does it really does
and it's not sticking to your teeth we
sure alright guys well thanks for
watching alright I need thank you guys
for joining in this random taste test
right
there's your couch behind you looks in
hideous with this decor ed test
you know feels good